Как перестать быть шарашкиной контент?
Я очень сильно благодарен этому году.
Нам никто не говорил, что такое
независимость Казахстана. Если бы
Касамжратукаевы поехал бы вкибастус, это
было бы кемб.
Как вы встретили январь?
Тоже кричал: "Алла, Казахстан". Почему
молодых режиссёров всё-таки тянет на вот
такие трагические трагичные вещи? Когда
в компании произошла проблема,
руководитель должен пойти на то место,
где случилась проблема, разобраться и
принять там решение по решению этой
проблемы.
Лежала в гостинице, просто плакала. Вот
это непонимание друг друга уже
невозможно. Есть ли у девушек шансы
делать бизнес?
Насколько эффективен я, настолько
эффективен бизнес? Не забывайте
проживать эту жизнь и проживать эти
эмоции.
[музыка]
Добрый день, друзья. Приветствую всех на
нашем канале. Итак, мы начинаем наш
очередной предновогодний подкаст Гембо
подкаст. Прежде всего всех хочу
поздравить с прошедшим двадцать вторым
годом. Почему поздравить? Потому что
двадцать второй год не всем людям был
хорошим годом. И вообще он год такой
был, год, не скажу, что катастроф, но
определённых социальных потрясений. А
если вспомнить январь этого года, он был
тяжёлый для Казахстана.
Далее у нас февраль, а начало войны и
агрессии России против Украины, поэтому
в целом весь год прошёл под знаком
конфликтов, войн и так далее. Поэтому в
этом плане можно, я думаю, немного
встрепенуться, оглянуться назад. В то же
время мы все, я уверен, благодарны за
этот прожитый год, потому что навряд ли
найдётся человек, который неблагодарен
за то, что прожил ещё один год. А в
целом, если говорить по про двадцать
третий год, мы смотрим в этот год,
конечно, с большой надеждой, прежде
всего с большой надеждой, что а над нами
всеми будет мирное небо, что все люди
опять заживут нормальной, счастливой
жизнью, и наши планы будут сбываться, и
всё придёт в наше привычное, хорошее,
доброе русло. Поэтому с наступающим вас
двадцать третьим годом. Итак, начинаем
наш гемba подкаст. И прежде всего,
прежде чем, как, э, как начать этот GB
подкаст, я хочу сделать небольшое интро
и напомнить, что Gbao подкаast - это
особый формат подкаста, при котором мы
не приглашаем экспертов, мы приглашаем
просто людей, которые известны и
неизвестны. И это и бизнесмены, и люди
творческих профессий. А это м не
разговор о какой-то конкретной
направленной теме. Мы будем обсуждать в
целом обо всём. то, что волнует
общество, то, что волнует нас, а то, что
сейчас в тренде. А так как этот год
прошёл и перед нами
Новый год, а мы сегодня, конечно, будем
говорить о планировании, о стратегии на
двадцать третий год, как мы собираемся
жить, как мы провели двадцать второй
год, как мы собираемся жить
в двадцать третьем году, поделимся с
вами какими-то определёнными лайфхаками,
а стратегиями жизни, что мы ожидаем от
этого года и так далее. такие вот это
такая м посиделка между собочек, э где в
мы простой непринуждённой обстановке
поговорим в целом о жизни. Теперь, э,
ещё одно напоминание хотел бы сказать.
Что такое Гемба? Мне тоже многие задают
вопрос, что такое Гемba? Гемба - это
взята из японской кайдзен технологии. Э,
это
технология, которая применяется на в
компании Toyota. Это место, где
произошла проблема. То есть, когда в
компании произошла проблема,
руководитель должен поднять, грубо
говоря, свою задницу и пойти на то
место, где случилась проблема, и глазами
убедиться в этой проблеме, разобраться и
принять там решение по решению этой
проблемы. Это одно значение Гембы. И
второе значение Гембы - это точка или
место, где принимается решение или точка
принятия решений. Поэтому мы не спроста
назвали наш подкаст Гембой. И поэтому мы
берём какую-то общественно значимую
проблему, ставим на стол, её разбираем и
обсуждаем, как бы мы приняли решение в
этой ситуации. И так как год
завершается, мы сегодня решили обсудить,
как мы собираемся жить в двадцать
третьем году. И сегодня у нас по
традиции гости представляют сами себя.
Начинаем мы слева направо по часовой
стрелке. Арман, вам слово. Меня зовут
Арман Тоскамбаев. Мне 31 год. Я
предприниматель. А у меня шесть бизнесов
в разных отраслях. Это производство и
дистрибьюция бадов японских,
архитектурная компания и, наверное, одна
из таких моих известных компаний, по
которым меня узнают, это часовая
компания OTAN с гербом Казахстана.
Очень рад сегодня быть на Гембо
подкасте.
А, всем привет. Меня зовут Дина
Дауленова, мне 35 лет. Я живу в Корее.
Наша компания занимается экспортом
корейской косметики
в Южной Корее. Ре, а то все путают
Северной. [смех]
Не интереснее звучало бы Северной Корее.
Косметику из Северной Кореи [смех]
занимается экспортом коммунизма. Да, я
занимаюсь экспортом северной
северокорейской рисовой косметики.
Да. Ээ рисовая тоже существует в
ингредиентах. А вот
всё так
всё понемножку.
Если бы Касмжумаратукаевы поехал бы в
якибастус, это было бы Гемб.
Да, это однозначно.
Меня зовут Фнат Безикеев. Я
режиссёр-документалист.
У меня автор проекта Замандас.
Всё, бул замандас.
Угу. Раскрой свою грудь.
Вот он замандас.
Да, замандас переводится как
современник. Да.
А меня зовут Амирхан. А все знают меня
как строителя коворкингов. А, но
последние 2 года я занимаюсь
автоматизацией парковок. Я называю меня
как бы я парковщиком. Компания паркур.
Вот всё.
Вот ты не имеешь отношения кто алматы
паркингу?
Нет, нет, нет. Кстати, один из
крупнейших. Ну как
в Казахстане номер один мы, да? Част
частном сегменте мы
Вы занимаетесь именно автоматизацией,
да? Парко,
да? То есть мы кратко расскажу, то есть
у нас технологии распознавания, то есть
мы распознаём номер, габарит, вид авто,
то есть мы в наших парковках нету людей,
нету билетов пластиковых.
Классно. А-а, то есть, распознаётся
номер, заходит машина, мобильная плата
онлайн, машина выезжает, как бы человек
заехал-выехал, как бы на этом всё как бы
вот оди.
Ну, классно, классно присутствует в
Южной Америке, в Дубае, да? В двадцати
странах.
О, классно. Вот, ну, мы, э, когда
приглашаем гостей на наш гемba подкаст,
мы, конечно, стремимся, чтобы гостями
нашего гемba подкаста были люди, которые
сами по себе интересны нашим зрителям.
Поэтому надеемся, подбор наших гостей не
случаен, вы это видите. Итак, давайте
перейдём. Первое, нам нужно раскидаться
и понять по двадцать второму году, у
кого что случилось, кто как его провёл,
как его он оценивает этот год вообще в
целом. А давайте откуда начнём? Кто есть
желающий? Первый, а потом все пойдём.
Так,
для меня двадцать второй год был очень
крутой. Хоть он не начался с трагических
событий в Казахстане, а за год мы
выросли шесть раз как бизнес, и большую
часть роста пришлось на вторую половину.
М зашли на новые рынки. А и для меня,
наверное, был ещё значим не только по
результатам, а именно в собственном
развитии. После моей поездки на Балхаш к
вам у меня действительно произошла такая
мощная трансформация. Я начал понимать
глубже саму суть бизнеса и ваш совет о
переходе на корпоративное управление
привело к тому, что я сейчас компании
выстраиваю такое корпоративное
управление, и люди нашлись, самое
главное, я думаю, достижением этого
года, 2022- это то, что в мою команду
перешли топ-менеджеры очень крупных
компаний из СНГ, то есть таких больших
гигантов, как тетрапак, как Тирила,
масло делал. То есть у меня вот в
команде сейчас такие люди
благодаря мобилизации.
А
не только, наверное,
не только. Да,
да. Угу.
Потому что мы даже по клубу вим, видим,
у нас в казенклубе очень много людей
приехало с Украины, например, с Чехии,
ну, с Европы, там, с России в том числе.
Ну, большая часть у меня 70%, ну, как
90% - это казахстанцы. Это, знаешь, у
меня, наверное, больше с того, что
пришло понимание того, что я вот
операционист, который сам всё бегает и
делает на своём уровне. Но вот поговорю
с Марлом Количным, у меня открылся новый
перспектив, увидел, что нужно строить
чуть иначе бизнес.
Причём вопрос его звучал так: Марголан
Колевич, как перестать быть шарашкиной
конторой? [смех] Дадада он звучал именно
так, как перестать быть шарашкиной
конторой, хотя у него большая компания
при этом. И вообще,
да, я арманно узнал, я узнал по тому,
что вы дарили часы нашему первому
президенту, наверное, да. А ещё
любопытный факт про него сказать,
знаешь, что он мой хейтер.
Жёсткий хейтер.
Да, ничего себе.
Так что вот от хейтера
спинор, да?
Так, Дина, как у тебя двадцать второй
год? Прошёл. Ой, боюсь даже начинать,
потому что год был достаточно очень
интересный, можно сказать,
трансформативный, да? Потому что, аэ,
начался нормально, но получилось так,
что,
а, я начала тратить очень много денег.
Ну, то есть, э,
так, так, так,
да, в жизни столько денег не тратила. Но
получилось так, что именно этот год,
познавая себя, а очень много трат,
который я до сих пор остановиться не
могу. Вот это во-первых. Во-вторых, год
очень интересный. Мы в этом году
разрабатывали свой бренд, а вышли,
получается, вот в течение 3 лет работаем
с Магнитом. И привело к тому, что а
создали свой бренд и сейчас получили
первые заказы.
Угу. А вот второе - это больше,
наверное, познание сего, что я вот на
наставничество к вам попала благодаря, а
посетила Багитур, где вот это и
трансформация произошла.
Вот
что-то я вроде учу зарабатывать деньги,
а не тратить деньги, да?
Ну, ну больше, наверное, хочется меньше
работать и больше, как говорится,
наслаждаться, не только деньги считать,
да. Вот в этом плане, наверное, где-то я
до сих пор себя познаю, не могу найти. А
в целом очень интересно, потому что
очень много стран посетила Японию. Вот с
вами тоже ездили очень круто.
А в Баги и слёт, очень интересный слёт
был, кстати, в Турции.
Угу. А
конечно, первый слёд был намного
интереснее. То есть в целом финансы мы
до конца ещё не досчитали, но мы в
плюсе.
Классно. Это хорошо. Она у тебя как
двадцать второй?
Ну, слушайте, двадцать второй год у меня
он был разным. Э, и от отчаяния до там
ненависти, до любви. А хочу сказать, что
я очень сильно благодарен этому году. Я
искренне рад, что было всё, что в нём. В
профессиональном плане я м ну очень
также развиваюсь. Я сделал несколько
больших документальных фильмов, ушёл
больше в продюсирование. А мы создали
проект вот за Мандаз. Мы целый год были,
ну, у нас уже зрители, может знают,
может нет. Мы были, ну, очень активно в
этом году с разными кейсами. То есть у
меня проект моих современников, я где,
так сказать, документирую летопись своих
ровесников, да, своих знакомых, друзей,
и
я больше, наверное, ушёл в это. Аа я
построил дом родителям. Он у меня очень
много сил отнял, энергии, и я сейчас
просто, может быть, в том состоянии
сейчас накапливаюсь. Ну, знаете, когда
Ну, ты перечислил, слушай, накапливаюсь.
Что-то не похоже на накаплива.
Ну, в плане того, что я вот достиг своей
цели в этом году и у меня нету сейчас же
я у меня нету никаких там условно сейчас
целей, да? То есть я вот сейчас люди
говорят, когда обычно там они сдают
[музыка] большую там диссертацию
докторскую, они у них там 3-4 месяца
в таком пространстве депрессии. Ну не
то, что я не хочу сказать, что у меня в
депрессии, я просто таком в ожидании от
вот собирание потенла,
да, собираюсь в отпуск отдохнуть. И
А какие документальные фильмы в этом
году снял?
Ну у меня в этом году вот год был
тяжёлый и два тяжёлых документальных
фильма. Это вот фильм вышел весной Зима
в рехабе называется. Я
документировал жизнь ну реабилитационном
центре государственном, да, людей,
которые живут и проживают
хаб, да, то есть, ну, ле, да, лечатся,
да, от наркозависимости, от
алкозависимости игромани.
И у меня вот вышел недавно фильм также у
меня на YouTube канале это про
посмертное донорство называется Лист
ожидания.
Да, тяжёлые фильмы и оба. И вот этот год
как бы интересно то, что Да, почему-то
А вообще вот смотри, темы твоих фильмов
кто задаёт?
Я считаю, что они меня сами как-то вот
находят. Если зима в рехабе фильм, то
человек, который находился в этом
рехабе, написал мне искреннее письмо, на
которое я отвлёкся, и решил поехать и
встретиться с этим человеком. Ну, то
есть получается, ты, мм, э, у тебя терм,
тем появляется от тем, э, которые тебя
наиболее эмоционально зацепили, да?
Да. Я, ну, интуитивно вижу, что я могу,
то есть я могу как бы своё ремесло,
через своё ремесло рассказать эту
историю, и я начинаю просто изучать. А
фильм про посмертное донорство я
прочитал пост журналист Оксана Акулова.
Она писала пост про, ну, она несколько
лет уже пишет статьи про эту тему. Я
наткнулся на её статию статью на сайте
Влакизz и вдохновился. Ну, то есть
прочитал, вдохновился. И мы с, ну, своим
продюсером Кайратом Нурмагобетовым
поняли, что это наша следующая история и
которую я начал год назад.
Ну, и год я её делал.
Угу.
То есть больше как-то делал.
Немного отвлекаясь от темы. Вот недавно
я ходил на премьеры фильма Каш.
Угу. А нашего соотечественника
Айсултана, который очень круто на Западе
снимал много клипов, раскрутился и так
далее. Кстати, мы там с тобой друг друга
увидели. И вопрос вот почему молодых
режиссёров всё-таки тянет на вот такие
трагические трагичные вещи? Это какой-то
э что какая-то профессиональная вообще
черта или или что? Или почему? Вот
странно.
То есть вроде с одной стороны смотришь,
вроде есть тренд на комедии, да? Угу.
Комедии делают там, ну, самое
интересное, что комедии делают не
профессиональные
киношники.
Ну, мы, наверное, в этом плане Сисултан
может и похожи. Мы не идём по простому
пути и идём по пути, к которому нам
нравится и где мы можем себя реализовать
как режиссёры. Да,
я режиссёр не игрового кино, у меня
вообще подход. Я пришёл к я
документалист, я пришёл из журналистики
к этому, из фоторепортёрства. То есть у
меня вообще
я не киношник, как вот, наверное, ваши
ребята, да, вот которые за кадром, они
более киношные, возможно. То есть они
как кино знают больше, чем я.
Я больше, наверное, мне нравится
информация. А что Айслтана вдохновило,
это, ну, наверное, ещё поиск, знаете,
идентичности. Мы то поколение, которое
наше старшее поколение жило по одному
порядку. Мы выросли в независимом
Казахстане. Нам никто не говорил, что
такое независимость Казахстана. Ну, то
есть условно нам не дали не дали чёткого
понимания, кто что кто такие
казахстанцы, что такое быть казахом. Да,
мы росли
знаете, вот, ну, как пойдёт,
а в какой-то момент ты взрослеешь и
начинаешь задаваться вопросом: "А кто мы
друг другу?"
Угу.
И я думаю, наверное, вот где-то ответ
кроется ещё в этом. что мы каждый ищем
для себя, кто мы. И Филим Хаш, наверное,
и Султана, он, наверное, больше ещё об
этом. Ну, я имею в виду, примерно
понимаю его отношение к этому фильму.
Что самое интересное, я когда
познакомился ещё с с А Султаном, до
этого до фильма, он ещё летом меня
пригласил на премьеру, говорил, что вот
я снимаю такой фильм, который значимый
для меня и так далее. Я ему сразу
сказал, что, ну, там там коммерческой
частью там не пахнет,
чтобы ты осознавал и не было завышенных
ожиданий, что ты на этом деньги
заработаешь. Он говорит: "Нет, у меня
даже таких ожиданий нет".
И интересно, что вот человек, понимая,
что у фильма нет коммерческой
перспективы, всё равно для него это
такой гештальд, нужно было закрыть,
сделать. Интересно. Амирхан, у тебя как
2?
Да, я, да, немного про каната хочу ещё
сказать. А, да, на самом деле я слежу 10
лет примерно к попули, да, по-моему, с
всего с всего с этох проектов
фоторепортажей, да, началось.
Спасибо.
А прямо фолловер. Ты не чувствовал,
[смех] ты не чувствовал, что за тобой
следят?
Ощут мой такой, мы редко видимся, но
очень, я его считаю своим старшим.
Меня было ощущения, что за тобой следят
10 лет.
Не, нет.
Тем более парковка, видеблюдения,
передвижение машин. Так,
да. И на самом деле поднимает ээ сложные
темы, то есть видно, что важно как бы
содержание, э, очень такие смысловые
репортажи были смысловые видео разные. А
даже в этом году, когда заманда
смотришь, иногда вытаскивает таких
людей, которые в жизни никогда не
слышал. Например, для меня там я сам
родом и Шинкенто. Оказывается, там есть
крутой рэпер, рокер этот Шиза.
Шиза
прямо он оказывается прямо
фундаментальное влияние на казахский
рэп.
Да.
Да. А про это никто не знает, например,
да? То есть он в своё время был круче,
чем скриптонит. И вот интересные вещи,
как бы, как он тексты там складывает.
Для меня это вообще новая, далекая от
меня сфера, но много чего интересного
узнаю. И то, что интересно ещё вот
последние несколько месяцев наблюдаю,
канат начал вести на казахском подкаст.
О, это круто,
да? То есть для тебя же не первый язык,
как бы.
Подкаст - это видеоподкаст или аудио?
Видеока.
Видеоподка, да, да. То есть там у него
прямо трансформация идёт на глазах. Это
тоже интересно наблюдать. Итересно это
плане. Это круто. Это круто.
А касательно меня вот мой бизнес
относительно новый. Мы там открыли
середине двадцатого года. И в этом году
мы выходили, начали выходить за рубеж. А
[фыркает] один из интересных вещей, я 21
февраля поехал в Москву открывать
филиал. Вот как раз тогда я виделся
Срманом башня федерация. Через 3 дня
понял, что уже пора закрываться. [смех]
Я рассказал ему цены.
Вы чтобы не попасть под мобилизацию
область [смех] России чухнули.
Да, дада. Сам, на самом деле, год был
интересный. А я в том плане, что
последние 3-4 года они интересные, да,
начиная с двадцатого.
Несмотря на то, что было много
потрясения, в целом, как бы уже привык к
неопределённости. В этом году как раз мы
начали [откашливается] выходить за
рубеж. Мы уже, как Арман сказал, в
двадцати странах работаем. Только-только
где-то получается, где-то не получается,
как бы где-то не воспринимают. Например,
в Америке там люди говорят: "Вы кто там?
Ты китайц или русский?" Да, как бы.
[смех] То есть когда ты пытаешься из
Казахстана тащить технологию в Америку.
Во-первых, никто не слышал про
Казахстан. Никаких хороших отсоциств не
возникает. А, во-вторых, все подозревают
том, что тебя упаковали либо китайцы,
либо русские, которым рынок Америки уже
закрыт. В этом плане много интересного
узнал то, что там определённый
культурный рассизм, несмотря на весь
этот американский диверсиity или
европейский диверсиity там или
мультикультурализм,
это всё существует. Это прямо на уровне
бизнеса, например, да, существует.
Например, там
мы там продаём парковки большим
компаниям по недвижимости. Если,
допустим, в Нью-Йорке ты не еврей,
ирландец или итальянец, сложно попасть в
хорошую аудиторию, например. Вот это на
прямо на культуру.
Ну ты,
в принципе, ирландцам, итальянцем там ты
не можешь стать. [смех]
Ну одна дорожка у тебя открыта,
да. Мне сказали, там нужно
инкорпорироваться в Израиль и оттуда
ехать в Штатами. Но самое главное то,
что как бы интересно год был интересным
тем, что я уже ездил в эти страны не для
того, чтобы как турист, да, отдыхать, а
пытаться делать бизнес. Аа и как бы и
это ну как бы много чего интересного как
бы в этом плане было. То есть трудности,
сложности, интереса. Вот.
Ну то двадца второй год ты доволен?
Да, я где-то 80% провел за рубежом от
Дубая до Штатов, поэтому
А вот теперь смотрите, давайте хорошо
возьмём
аа январь.
Угу. самый такой трагичный месяц в
Казахстане. Вот как вы встретили январь?
Вот давай вот прямо теперь в обратную
сторону идём. Говорим [фыркает] только
про январские события. А вот для страны
это была трагедия, но для меня это как
как сказать, то есть вот прямо третьего
или четвёртого, когда это первый день
начался, мы там сначала покатались,
потом в сауну пошли и потом я приехал
домой и потом э начались эти события. А
вот друзья со в Алмаате, да, я был в
Алмаате как раз. Друзья просто с
администрации президента, я не знаю, там
были люди с администрации президента,
они сказали, как бы позвонили, сказали:
"Нужно следующую неделю просто провести
дома, никуда не выходить".
Угу.
Просто я не знал, я позвонил, люди,
которые я они не занимают вверх такие
какие-то высокие позиции, они там
рядовые там аналитики, они сказали, вот
я просто им сказал, что творится, что
ожидать. Они сказали: "Как бы ничего не
предпринимай, ничего не делай, просто
неделю проведи дома".
Угу. как бы в этом плане я там неделю
провл дома, дома недалеко от площади,
как бы всё это видел. Но в целом, как
бы, если смотреть с моей личной, с
личного опыта, для меня это было как бы
относительно легко, да, я дома провёл,
но в целом как бы как бы ну интернета
нет, пытался читать, как бы
переживал за родных, друзей, которые
тоже там по городу ходили, как бы вот
личный опыт он такой простой, но в целом
как бы ну для страны трагичный.
Карат, ты Январ как? Ну, я был, а,
четвёртого, я вышел, они проходили,
проходили мимо моего дома по оба. Я
видел на эту линейку толпу и не мог
сидеть дома. И я вышел, вышел
посмотреть, кто же вышел.
Угу.
И всё, как, знаете, как на футбольном
поле. Ну, как ты входишь в толпу, и ты
становишься частью толпы. Я стал на
какой-то момент частью толпы.
Скандир, ну тоже кричал: "Алла
Казахстан!" И какой-то вот мне миг духа
был такой.
Ну ты попал в начальную здоровую часть
сам начальную. Ну то есть на Аба Абая
Гагарин, да. Люди шли из Салматарено и
вот Бабая. Я вот с Гагарина дошёл до
Байтутрсунова шёл. И на какой-то момент
просто я понял, что мне хочется домой.
Я, ну, я не видел, то есть для меня было
ощущение, то есть до этого же тоже люди
выходили, но меня было, наверное,
разгонят. И как-то я не думал, что всё
это обернётся так, как это обернулось. Я
решил вернуться домой к семье, э, к жене
и сыну. И что было на самом деле очень
хорошей идеей по итогу.
А пятого утром проснулся уже от
выстрелов уже дымаша, когда уже армия
уже тащила толпу назад. То есть это всё
было мимо моего дома.
Ну я также в тот момент сразу принял
решение, что мы никуда не выходим, мы
будем дома. А мой отец родной был,
оказывается, он тоже он был,
оказывается, на площади на каком-то
моменте. Я это уже узнал на следующий
день.
Угу.
Вот. И, конечно, у меня были и
переживания, и я очень всё это больно
больно проживал этот момент. Просто
потому что, ну, я как бы был, я видел и
как это потом всё это обернулось, э, что
имир из мирных людей сделали
террористами, потому что я это всё
видел. И, конечно, мы сидели просто в
ожидании какого-то,
а, ну, сказать, чуда. Даже любое в тот
момент, конечно, любое высказывание
президента для тебя было уже каким-то
таким.
Либо вы идёте в ту сторону, либо вы
идёте в хорошую. Была, конечно, надежда.
Ну, по итогу
я считаю, что что сейчас вот в течение
год, да, как всё это, ну, это, по мне
такое какое-то как будто лицемерие, что
ли, произошлогу
вот связано с Кантаром. И нельзя вот так
взять и, ну, обесценить то, что было.
Угу. Дина, ты где была?
А, у меня были незавершённые дела,
которые я всё время откладывала. Мне
нужно было лететь в Ташкент. И я,
представляете, целый год откладывала это
дело, потому что, ну, [фыркает] думаю,
не такое важное. И получилось так, что
Новый год я решила встретить в
Казахстане. Угу.
Я второго числа я не могла дома сидеть.
У меня такое ощущение было, как будто
вот нужно закрыть вопрос. Я беру билет
на третье число и улетаю, никому не
говорив. Просто говорю маме, я говорю,
хочу этот завершить дела. И вылетаю,
прилетаю в Ташкент, начинаю работать,
свои вопросы закрывать. И тут не могу
дозвониться, вообще не понимаю, что
происходит. Э до кого не могу ни
дозвониться, ни писать. Потом откуда-то
узнала, что
творится вообще в Казахстане. Это было,
наверное, м несколько дней самых таких,
наверное, бессонных ночей. Когда ты
вообще реально неинформирована, ты не
знаешь, что происходит и чем помочь. И
вот это состояние, наверное, я помню,
лежала в гостинице, просто плакала. А
потом уже хорошо вот в чате многие стали
вот через а получается сервер, через
Telegram как-то вот этот попытались,
получается написать сообщение. узнала,
что этот, и всех просила, потому что у
меня есть братишки, племянники, которые
болеют какой-то кипиш, могут выйти
гормоны молодые. И просила, чтобы они
сидели [откашливается] дома.
И благо мама живёт в частном доме, то
есть у нас не было проблем с провизией.
То есть то я слышала, что у друзей не
было ни денег, ни хлеба, потому что мы
привыкли каждый раз
оплачиваться всё через Каспи. И продукты
каждый день берём не так этот вот такие
вот очень сильно. То есть этот год
начало, конечно, запомнился надолго.
Угу. Очень хорошо.
Арман, ты как?
Я прямо погрузился в те воспоминания
январские. Ну, наверное, самое большое
впечатление, которое для меня сложилось,
это был такой сильнейший страх. Страх
именно за будущее. Там вопросы бизнеса
или каких-то таких вещей, они были
вторичны.
Угу. А было страшно именно заботаще. Тем
более приходили такие новости о вводе
войск ОДКБ, а о том, что там солдаты
будут российские там топтать по нашей
земле и там в случае, если какой-то, не
знаю, провокации или там
каких-либо там эксцессов, да, может там
какая-то заварушка произойти. А,
наверное,
такое яркое воспоминание, когда м горело
вот это здание акимата. Угу. Я был таким
человеком, который просто
наблюдателем, да, со стороны и
здание горит, я стою перед ним. И, ну,
такое жуткое ощущение, что это, ну, как
будто ты во сне находишься, а это
неправда.
А, ну для меня это было вот такой
Ну что, ты где был в это время? На
площади был. А это было уже по после
Садьбыти, когда уже там разгон
закончился, здание горело очень долго.
Ну то есть оно продолжало, да? То есть
уже объявили, не помню, комендантский
час был там вечернее время суток, это
был день после. А все остальные дни,
когда это происходило, да, мы были дома
в Талгаре с родителями и
были просто такие так в вакууме, да,
потому что информация вся никакая не
поступала. Вот как затишее чуть-чуть
было, уже сообщали, начали каналы
какие-то включать, мы уже потихоньку
выбирались из города, чтобы посмотреть
офис. А у нас офис как раз рядом
находится с, э, за зданием акимата.
Угу.
Да. Январский ээ месяц январь
[откашливается] для всех, я думаю, в
Казахстане было таким потрясением. Меня
лично удивило то, что как быстро
общество может скатиться к дикости. Да,
очень быстро. Так, вроде вчера мы все
цивилизованно ходили в городе, а
покупали
продукты, как-то общались, тусовались, а
тут смотришь, здания горят, машины
перевёрнутые, там, э, люди с дубинками,
с оружием штурмуют там и так далее, и
так далее. Конечно. Но в этом плане мне,
например, помогло то, что, наверное, на
меня много людей смотрело, особенно
бизнесменов, соответственно, и все
задавали вопрос: что делать?
Соответственно, я не мог говорить, что я
не знаю, что делать. Соответственно, я
делал вид, что я знаю, что делать. Я я
что сделал? Я всех собрал дома. Собрал
дома, э, бизнесменов, кто был, внук, кто
обращался и так далее. И мы начали
составлять план, потому что в любой
непонятной ситуации надо сесть и
составлять план.
Мы сели составлять план, потом поехали
организовывать отряды самообороны,
потому что нужно что-то всё равно
делать. Я исходил из худшего сценария.
Во-первых, где-то на второй день я уже
примерно представлял, что это похоже на
какую-то провокацию или переворот,
потому что слишком легко КНБ захватили,
акимат, телерадиокомпанию,
всё они начали захватывать слишком
легко.
Плюс штурмы,
ГУВД,
оружие, я думаю. А потом вот эти машины,
которые разгоняют толпу, они шли, шли,
шли. Вдруг раз смотрю, теперь уже якобы
повстан рулём. Как они быстро захватили.
Потом солдаты вышли на площадь,
отцепили, вроде, потом раз, развернулись
и ушли всей толпой. Ну, как бы я понял,
что сверху идёт противо идут
противоречивые команды. И я понял, что
здесь пахнет э переворотом. Поэтому моя
задача была отцепить наш район, потому
что уже разговоры шли, что вот они идут
грабить верхние районы. Ну, обычно же,
а, по крайней мере такой миф, что в
случае, если что случится, будет грабить
верхние районы. И вот слухи были, там
уже бот бульвар, там вот выше бот
ботанического сада, там уже ограбили,
там это и скоро в частный сектор придут
и так далее. Поэтому цель была такая
локальная. Эла была управлять тем, что в
моих в моих компетенциях, в моих
полномочиях то, что я могу изменить. Я
не заморачивался по поводу всего
остального. Я видел, что ситуация очень
плохая, в плохую сторону идёт, но в то
же время понимал, что моя задача
конкретно локально локализовать проблему
и придумать какие-то контрмеры.
В целом [откашливается]
в тот момент, конечно, было недо
переживаний. А, ну вот январь, наверное,
уже все знают, как он прошёл. Долго мы
останавливаться не будем. Я специально
небольшую остановку сделал, потому что
двадцать второй год, не отметив январь,
будет неправильно, конечно. Второе
большое событие - это война. Это когда
Россия напала на Украину. Это был,
конечно, шок. Это был шок. А причём
такой вообще немыслимый. Это второй
немыслимый. Два раза нам э реально мозг
взорвали. Как вообще такое может быть? Я
вообще считал, что это в принципе
невозможно,
но это случилось. А давай давайте
вкратце расскажем, как вот войну теперь
встроители. Я же жил в это время в
Москве с ноября месяца, ну, позапрошлого
года.
А у меня квартира на Кутузовском
проспекте находится.
И то есть вот это Совет Федерации или
как здание наверно называется, да, на
Кутузовском. Угу.
И каждый день с утра, весь январь, я
видел вот эти на мигалках, вот эти
кортеджи, которые 6:00 утра начинают там
ездить,
а у меня окно смотрят из спальня туда. И
каждый день я вот этот шум видел.
Ну вот это вот напряжение на этом
проспекте в Москве, оно вот ощущалось.
когда объявили войну, конечно, все мы у
меня были грандиозные планы на то, что
двадца четвётого ты где был в феврале?
Я прямо сидел в квартире.
А прямо в Москве там?
Да, в Москве сидел. Мы все были
прикованные к телевизору. Я в
оцепенении, наверное, 3-4 дня правил. То
есть я смотрел на эти новости. Я перевёз
туда 17 человек в Москву семьи. Мы
перевезли головной офис компании и
планировали вот выход на европейский
рынок, работу в самой России, да. Я и
для меня это было такое отцепенение. Я
тут приехал и такое случается, да? А 3-4
дня просто завис, а потом упаковали
чемодан и поняли то, что ну
работать так и здесь я не могу же.
А вот то, что ты офис открыл башня
федерация, там сколько времени там
сколько месяцев-то?
Мы проработали 4 месяца. И помимо этого
у нас в Москве ещё было два больших
офиса. Один склад и второй офис на 250
квадратов. То есть у нас было три офиса.
Головной мы закрыли, оставили два
и оставили региональное
представительство.
Угу. Дина, ты 24 февраля?
Я вообще в начале вот если убрать
январских событий, да, скажем там, а
войну, я хотела с вами в Килиманджара
и готовилась и думала вот-вот. И потом
получилось январские события в Ташкент,
и мне нужно было возвращаться в Корею.
Угу. И именно в этот день, получается, я
была в Корее. Когда услышала,
было, конечно, немножко страшновато, так
как у меня экспортная компания находится
в Южной Корее и мы работаем с СНГ, и
один из хороших объёмов, который
занимает - это Россия.
Плюс Бишкек, там Киргизстан, Узбекистан,
всё, что мы продаём, в итоге конечный
слив идёт это Россия.
Угу. И когда вот начали многие компании
уходить, выводить этот, и я думала, что
делать вообще, как вообще в дальнейшем
будет, да, всё, что происходит, бизнес,
ладно, но тем не менее друзья, которые
там живут. И действительно, вот как
карман говорит, а очень сильное
разделение мнения пошло. И получилось
так, что с кем мы раньше дружили, они
вообще перестали отвечать на звонки.
Угу. Некоторые очень плохо настроены
были клиентами, которые тоже
общались, работали, многие тоже. То есть
сразу было видно, кто за кого, кто этот.
Хотя в тот момент мы не понимали
действительно, что происходит. И
было только, наверное, ждать и понимать,
что делать дальше.
Угу. То есть это было ужасно, потому что
я думала, если, например, а закроет
вообще Корея откажется, то что делать
вообще? Какой бизнес, когда ты этим
живёшь? И да,
и очень много должников, которые
взаиморасчёты ещё не произвели. То есть
было страшно. Мне реально было страшно.
А ты в Корее уже сколько лет живёшь? А
первый раз я уехала в 2012 году.
10 лет уже. Да.
Да.
Да, 10 лет уже.
Угу. Ну вот последние 4-5 лет я
постоянно вот в Корее.
Угу. Ну ты по-корейски говоришь уже.
Корейский говорю. Да, в плане работы, но
я не скажу, что прямо круто
разговариваю. Вот. Потому что
никто и не ожидает такие [смех] круто
разговаривать. Не можежно проверить.
Не, ну ты, что ты говоришь, уже хорошо.
И, кстати, вот, девчата, вот яркий
пример. Девушка уехала в Южную Корею,
создала [откашливается] там бизнес и вот
занимается экспортом косметики с Южной
Кореей. А причём я тут одна в Корее, то
есть у меня не было ни опоры, никого.
Все родные, близкие, они все в
Казахстане.
Угу.
Но вы всё испортили? [смех]
Я всё испортил. Опять я виноват.
У меня у меня тоже племянница есть. Она
уехала. Вот она любила любила печь
выпечку, торты.
И она с детства хотела быть
бизнесменшей, бизнес-вуменшей. И она
делала, делала после школы, и она не
поступила никуда. И она после школы это
делала, у неё бизнес хорошо получался. И
она решила открыть кафешку. И наши
власти не разрешили, потому что нет
высшего образования, нельзя,
оказывается, заниматься этим.
И она уехала в Южную Корею. Угу.
в Южную Корею она начала
работать вначале там помощником где-то в
каком-то кафе в Южной Корее, потом
начала делать выпечку там, потом стала
фудблогером. Она начала ну дегустировать
еду и делать обзоры. А ей за это
платили. Она содержала тем, что ей
платили за обзоры. Она приходила в кафе,
рестораны, бесплатно её кормили. Она
пробовала, потом писала обзоры. И таким
образом сейчас она живёт уже на в Японии
на
этом не на Хакайда, а какой ещё остров?
Остров Долгожителей.
А маленький остров прямо из Нансю
Хакайда. Там четыре острова было за
маленький остров, вот откуда все
должители. И она там сейчас
работает
этот, составляет блюда для для кап в
японском и так далее. Ещё куда-то.
Вот я к тому, что
мне задава задают периодические вопросы:
есть ли у девушек шансы делать бизнесы?
Конечно,
ребята, у всех есть шансы. Бизнес никак
не связан с какими-то гендерными
различиями. Вот вам пример Южная Корея,
пример моя племянница, которая сейчас
живёт на в этом в Японии на острове.
Эсто,
без поддержки сами пробились. Она ты как
войну встретил?
Ну, я за историей этого конфликта слежу
уже давно, с 2014 года, и, но тоже никак
не мог
представить, что
две страны будут воевать и что Россия
нападёт на Украину. как я встретил в
ужасе, как и многие для себя могу просто
подметить то, что, наверное,
Мюн Ояндын, наверное, да, можно сказать,
что именно в тот момент, когда это всё
произошло, я понял для себя, что я точно
хочу жить в Казахстане, что я буду здесь
жить, я буду вливаться в душу и
развивать. Э, то есть я понял, что я
всё-таки часть а коммьюнити большого,
да, часть страны и что, наверное, я могу
много что сделать и помочь. И в этом
самом плане я в своём ремесло, как
человек, который делает, ну, как
грузищер, как человек, который делает
контент, я буду собираюсь бороться и
воевать на своём пространстве и делать
больше контента. И почему я в этом году
в целом сделал большой уклон на свой
проект за Мандаз, это чтобы зрители были
м не под чтобы были уже свои герои
здесь, да, чтобы здесь были свои
проекты, свои YouTubeканалы,
чтобы мы за такие же ребята, как я,
просто были везде
и
могли говорить, вещать и предоставлять
зрителям контент тот качественный, тот,
который они могли, который раньше, если
мы, допустим, мы же также конкурировали
раньше и с контентом из России,
то есть мы все смотрели употреблять, да?
То есть ваш подкаст вот выйдет, да?
Раньше мог и выйти в это же время и
какой-нибудь подкаст российского
предпринимателя, и многие зрители могли
уйти туда.
А моя задача, ну, то есть в моём, чтобы
люди оставались и смотрели за Мандас.
Угу.
Чтобы, потому что мы можем влиять и
говорить какие-то вещи.
И, ну, для меня, наверное, было вот это.
Также и произошло. Многие, которые
видели заманда за этот год, произошло
тоже вот как амирхан трансформация. Я
моё отношение к языку поменялось, моё
отношение в целом к себе, к как нации,
казаху поменялось и то есть из
токсичного там какого-то человека
превратился вообще в другого человека,
да. И это это два фактора. Это БНхантар.
Ну, конечно, и Это двадцать
четвёртое.
Ну, ты сам закончил казахскую школу или
русскую? Я закончил сам каза, ну знаете,
я закончил такую казахшаор орсмяти,
знаете, где ты говоришь на уроках на
казахском, ты выходишь и вы все говорите
на аутентичная казахская
казахская школа условная, но я говорил,
я был русскоязычный, я вырос в Карагане,
ну я родился в Карагане в целом. У меня
круг как бы русскоязычный казахов.
[тяжело вздыхает] В какой-то момент я
говорил на нём. Потом у меня было
отрекание от него вот так, знаете, то
потом я уехал за рубеж, уехал в Америку.
Вообще казахским языком, с культурой
был.
А не связано. Потом проф, видимо,
произошла какая-то деколонизация у меня
в голове. И
я сейчас иногда какие-то вещи, которые я
мог сказать: "Лей, 10 назад там ребятам,
я сейчас вспоминаю". И мне просто
становится стыдно. Я вот недавно
вспоминал там случаи
очень интересный. Да, ну когда держа
интересные интересное происходит такой
момент движение.
Многие русскоязычные казаки начинают
сейчас реально серьёзно, наконец-то
серьёзно изучать казахский язык.
А я сам закончил казахскую школу в
глубокой
селе, ну, в Лултавской области, как
сейчас Лутавский район, там село, это
чисто казахское село, там русских вообще
никогда не было. А, и у нас всё
по-захски было. Ну, всё по, ну, такая
аутентичная казахская.
Ну, при этом я вырос вот такой семьи,
да. тичну, но сам отвлекался от неё и
говорил: "Вот я такой другой".
Понимаете, вот как?
Ну вот и я говорю к тому, что вот м
а и новый тренд пошёл такой. Вот есть
ребята, которые закончили там в Алмате,
в городах и так далее, рус русскую школу
либо казахскорусскую, как ты сказал,
школу,
и они начинают возвращаться в казахский
язык. И мне понравился такой термин, э,
ребята недавно где-то услышал, сказали:
"Уралманы в казахский язык". [смех]
То есть изначально по-казахски говорили,
потом период был, когда забросили, а
потом вернулись в казахский язык.
В этом я не вижу плохого. Это это не
негативноя красна. Мы как раз-таки вот
правильно я не Ну, во-первых, я не хочу
там иногда меня хвалят, вот, ну, там, о,
молодец. Я считаю, в этом нет ничего
такого похвального, потому что я, ну,
это не такое большое событие, я знал
язык.
Угу.
Я всегда просто я сам не хотел,
возможно, говорить где-то, понимаете? У,
и тут я просто мне нужно было просто вот
здесь где-то переключиться, включить. Я
такой: "А я же казах, ну, в этом плане
творческие люди молодцы. Вот в
Казахстане я хочу отметить наших
рэперов, артистов, они на самом деле
задали моду на казахский язык".
Это и Димаш Кудаберген, и наши рэперы
многочисленные и так далее. И плюс,
конечно, свой вклад дали вот эти комедии
на казахском языке. Люди, по крайней
мере, казахскоязычное кино начали
смотреть,
да. Угу.
Это всё, то есть люди творческих
профессий свой вклад мощный вносят.
Такое сделали. Да, конечно. Извиняется
ещё. Извиняюсь. А очень сильно влияет.
Вот вы же говорите, уехали в Америку,
да, например, вот я тоже до в Корее вот
долгое время жила. Для меня вот
казахский язык, ну вот мы тоже всё время
в казах школу я окончила, но тем не
менее мы на улице разговаривали на
русском, да, и получилось так, что в
Корее тоже там через несколько лет
пришло осознание, то что Казахстан, моя
страна, вот знаете, вот мне казахстан
вот это просыпается. Там нет такого.
Южноре южнокорейские [смех]
южнокорейская слеж
южнокорейще слети вот 24 февраля на язык
тоже очень сильно повлиял
я считаю что это
события да повлияли
скорее всего и повлиял он тоже то есть
как
да я как уже говорил двадцать первое я
полетел в Москву открывать офис наш
Москва - это если смотреть с точки
зрения рынка парковок это второй рынок
Европы после Лондона там население
где-то 15 млн в самой центре Москвы там
парковка стоит 7 долларов. Поэтому это
был такой большой рынок.
А когда я прилетел, я еду такси в
гостиницу, и там у таксиста был экран, и
там новости, и выступает Путин. Они как
раз был такой с признавали ЛНР ДНР 21
вечера.
Я первым делом звоню уже, у нас мы уже
несколько кризисов за последние лет
прошли, а я говорю: "Быстро переводите
деньги в доллары, и будет девальвация".
Потом Да, потом два чед четвёртого
наступила. Сам по себе, даже до этой
войны, если смотреть с точки зрения
венчурных инвесторов, технологии,
Россия, она всегда была такой серой
зоной. То есть венчурные инвесторы не
приветствовали делать бизнес в России,
потому что связано с большими
политическими рисками и
оценка компании падает, если есть бизнес
в России. В этом плане как бы это и то
даже без войны было сомнительное решение
делать бизнес в России, да. А двадцать
четвёртое я понял, что уже всё конец,
дальше думать не стоит, но я не смог
сразу билеты найти, а в итоге на 2
недели задержался. И так как я был из-за
эти сферы, э
пообщался опять же с друзьями, там
Министерства цифровизации, Астанаха, и в
эти 2 недели я потратил в Москве,
посещая московские офисы IT-компании
Wargaming, ИДЙвер, различные
IT-компании, рекламируяхап и Казахстан
как место релокации. Да, как бы [смех]
они тогда не понимали ещё, что будет. Да
нет, они даже они тоже уже понимали,
потому что тот жедрайвер - это
преимущественно американские венчурные
инвесторы, и они сказали: "Уже мы не
можем дальше финансировать, если будешь
находиться в Москве". Как бы это были
уже понятные такие шаги. И мы там
общались ходил бесплатным амбассадором
был 11 марта еле как выбрался в Ташкент.
Через Ташкент вернулся. Какое-то время
даже страна Иерастана прекратила рейсы
Москвы. Вот. А Украина была вторым
рынком, Киев был вторым рынком, где мы
вышли. Мы ещё вышли в конце года. В
итоге там, э, с Украину закрыли, там
буквально четыре человека, пять-шесть
парковок было, но рынок растущий, то
есть тоже Киев предполагался 2030 году в
Киеве будет жить до 8 млн человек. То
есть там большие планы тоже развития
были. В итоге в Москве Украину закрыли,
э, устремились в
Штаты больше как бы, но в целом, да, то
есть согласен с тем, что это имеет
большое культурное значение.
Угу. для постсоветского пространства, а
для
как бы такого национального самосознания
многих людей интересно будет наблюдать,
чем это закончится. Я думаю, у всех у
нас были, большинство из нас было
ожидание, что эта история рано или
поздно закончится либо тем, что Украина
быстро проиграет, либо тем, что Россия,
не добившись там под видом этих больших
санкций, в итоге ни то, ни второе не
случилось. Аа вот в этом плане я как бы
ожидаю, как бы на самом деле интересный
кейс. С одной стороны, Казахстан, можно
сказать, за последний год сильно
поменялся,
да,
а или есть попытки поменяться, да, и
геополитическая обстановка вокруг
меняется, как бы. И когда я с Америкой
встречаюсь, как бы, а люди, когда и
венчурным инвесторам, откуда, когда
спрашивают, откуда ты, они нашу зону
называют Broken Geography, испорченная
география.
Они говорят: "Почему ты из далёкой
страны там, условно, там из другой части
земного жара приехал развивать бизнес в
Америку? А я говорю, у нас на юге Иран
Афганистан, там парковки разовать не
смогу. Там, не знаю, с с востока это
Китай. Угу.
Там тоже делать нечего. По сути, сверху
там Россия, если Запад смотреть, там
тоже неспокойно. Там Азербайджан,
Армения тоже между собой воют, как бы
кроме как в какой-то степени напоминает
геополитическую ситуацию Израиля, да,
как бы вроде там вокруг большие рынки,
большие страны, но ты не можешь ничего
сделать, потому что это всё закрыто, там
как бы
не самая лучшая атмосфера для ведения
бизнеса.
Да, двадцать второй год. Второе
крупнейшее событие - это, конечно, война
России с Украиной. А давайте плавно
перейдём на третью часть двадца второго
года. А вкратце, чтобы у нас осталось
больше времени про говорить про двадцать
третий год. А двадцать второй год
поговорим. У нас, а, наверное, из таких
крупных событий, ну, что можно отметить,
изменения в конституцию, выборы
президента. Вкратце скажите своё мнение.
Не буду спрашивать, где вы были в тот
момент, это уже не так имеет значения.
Просто своё отношение к этому и надежды,
связанные с этими двумя событиями. Это
изменение в конституцию и выборы
президента.
Может оттуда начнём? [смех]
Нет. У нас по традиции теперь уже пошло.
Давай.
[откашливается]
А
тяжёлый вопрос.
Да, тяжёлый вопрос тем, что мне часто
нечего сказать относительно а выборов
там изменения конституции, потому что я
их не принимаю.
У меня внутри было такое, что опять идёт
та история, когда с переписыванием
конституции, а очень скорые, скажем так,
назначения выборов. А также я знаю
людей, которые там, аэ, пытались в это
время построить партию, выдвинуть её, и
все эти попытки пресекались, и никакого
жана Хазастана я здесь вообще не чуил,
не видел. Для себя я решил уже давно,
что хочу быть мм
бизнесменом, который будет, скажем так,
в свой вклад вносить именно через
бизнес. А для этого мне нужно стать
очень крепко на ноги по миру. Угу.
Поэтому, несмотря на то, что происходит,
то есть стараясь не оглядываться на то,
что сейчас происходит, не зацикливаться
на этом негативе, о том, что вот там вот
это плохо, вот это сейчас, я для себя
решил сфокусироваться на том, что я
отточусь сейчас как бизнесмен, я построю
бизнес очень сильный по миру и начну
отдавать назад Казахстану через развитие
образования. Поэтому у меня год сейчас
идёт такой подготовки к выходу на такую
международную арену спортив такого
профессионального, да, вида бизнеса. И
относительно выборов я ничего не могу
сказать.
Понятно, Дина.
А у меня тоже, во-первых, я не сильно в
политике и, честно говоря, нету доверия.
То есть всё, что постоянно происходит и
иногда даже сомнения, действительно ли
выборы правильно проходят. Поэтому я
тоже больше тоже в планах выйти на
зарубежный рынок. Мы сейчас, э-э, тоже
дополнительно как второе направление -
это выйти на маркетплейсы. Также вот
конечный Amazon, на корейские сети тоже
очень много. Вот поэтому
2023 у меня больше зациклена на развитие
своего бизнеса.
Угу. Понятно.
Так, изменение конституции, что 7 лет,
да, поменял вот это изменение основное,
да? Ну, изменение конституции, то, что
убрали всё-таки статус есть басы из
конституции очень важно.
И выборы проведён.
Ну давайте вот начну насчёт выбора.
Можно не так прямо подробно, как
политолог. Мы не политологи,
да? Да. Я просто могу транслировать
примерно то, что думаю я и думают мои
там друзья, знакомые, близкие.
Ну я думаю, что в этих выборах нет было
смысла, по моим подсчётам, через 2 года
бы он же через 2 года должен был
баллотироваться. И я вижу сейчас некую
копипаст политтехнологов из России, что
команда Касжортукаева прямо копирует
действие, то, что было у соседней
страны. Я вижу большую пропаганду и
большое влияние государственных
бюджетных денег на имидж нашего
президента. Я считаю, что это
бессмысленно. Он работает на внешнюю
политику. Он забыл о том, что происходит
у нас внутри страны. Он, мне кажется,
потихоньку начинает даже терять терять
диалог э с гражданами. Хотя в январе, я
скажу, в начале года была на него
большая надежда и вера. И и среди
молодёжи он без больших влияния вот
этого пропаганды он уже у него был
неплохой рейтинг.
Угу. И я думаю, ему нужно было в этом
году всё-таки обратись. Я надеюсь, что
что всё-таки ему подскажет, что надо
обратить внимание всё-таки на проблему
внутренних институтов, потому что они
действительно рушатся. И по этим
институтам можно понять его отношение,
отношение власти имущих к стране. И, ну,
у меня прямо не то чтобы разочарование,
но я прямо вот сижу и так думаю: "Ну
почему вот рядом вот вам никто не
подскажет? Это же всё вроде бы
очевидно". Даже случаи с мемориалом
Кантару, да.
Угу.
В мировом опыте есть, что вот, по-моему,
там 5 лет проходит, ставят мемориал, да,
какому-то событию, быстро в тайне
сделали, построили, как попало, просто
плевок этому событию. Ну, я считаю, что
это неуважительно к народу. Угу. Из это
можно было сделать классный конкурс,
чтобы мы
люди продюсеры все бы могли бы
посоревноваться идеями, как это могло бы
сделать так красиво. И в целом вот этот
участок в городе, он очень сейчас, ну,
как мне кажется, не знаю, я туда не
езжу, то есть меня туда не тянет, меня
этот меня эта улица не привлекает, меня
она для меня она тяжёлая, там аура
тяжёлая. Я думаю, что почему ему не
подсказали? Почему он это же вроде бы
как бы элементарные же вещи, и я вижу,
что я не вижу ничего в этом
положительного. А,
Угу.
Ну, если вот так просто,
да, ну, крупными мозками. Архан,
да. То есть, кратко скажу, то есть, да,
после января было такое вовлечение в
политику, да, то есть, по крайней мере,
интерес вырос, были большие ожидания, а
потом произошли вот эти изменения в
конституцию. какую-то часть изменений он
не стал выносить на голосование там
через сенат провёл тоже, да. То есть, э,
на самом деле, да, были противоречивые
вещи, э, в том плане, что увеличение на
7 лет срока. И показалось, что вот ээ
как бы всегда можно найти обоснование,
там геополитические риски,
пятое-десятое, нужно укрепить во власть,
там старая элита там занимается
реваншизмом, пятое десятое. Но то, что
как это было сделано, оно обратно,
скажем так, оттолкнуло. То есть большие
ожидание о том, что будет
демонополизация, будет там больше
демократии, больше уважения прав
человека. Это всё как бы, по крайней
мере, за это достичения года это не
оправдались.
Поэтому я тоже уже как бы вот этого
вовлечения, воодушевления нет. Я просто
взял там обратно от страницы.
Отлично. Пошли.
Теперь только бизнес у нас.
Ну в целом [смех]
в целом вы видите это такой небольшой
стресс. Это конечно не мы не претендуем,
не думаю, что у вас были весёлые
подкасты. Не, ну мы не претендуем на
статистически значимое исследование, но
в целом вот мы за столом пять человек
сидим. Вот мнение четырёх человек вы
знаете, моё мнение вы знаете по другим
моим постам и так далее. Здесь я не буду
а своё мнение высказывать. А я потому
что всё время по каждому событию писал
посты и высказывал своё мнение. А в
целом да, год прошёл таким образом, мы
двадцать второй год подытожили. Двадцать
второй год в целом был невесёлый. Это не
вопрос подкаста. Если бы был год, у нас
подкаст был быческий.
Я вам скажу, что мы тоже записывали
итоги годов и, ну, у нас там истерическо
очень грустный грустный подкаст
получился. И это не специально даже,
да, это не специально. Год такой. Мы
сейчас говорим про двадцать второй год.
И сейчас мы перейдём к двадцать третьему
году стратегии жизни в двадцать третьем
году. Я думаю, здесь будет там у нас
повеслее. А причём мы назвали этот
подкаст Стратегия жизни на двадцать
третий год. А я чётко понимаю различия
между стратегией, тактикой и так далее,
планами. Э, может быть, чтобы лишний раз
я отвечаю хейтерам: "Смотрите, стратегия
красивее звучит. Тактика на двадцать
третий год звучала бы не очень красиво.
Поэтому мы назвали это стратегия на
двадцать третий год". А для того, чтобы
было общее, чёткое понимание, что такое
стратегия, и для людей, которые в этом,
может быть, не сильно разбираются,
стратегия - это плановая, эффективная
линия поведения для достижения, для
эффективного достижения своих
долгосрочных целей. Вот что такое
стратегия? Это плановое линие
эффективного поведения для достижения
своих долгосрочных целей. Отличие
стратегий от планов. В планах есть
конкретные цели, в планах есть
конкретные даты и измеримые показатели.
В стратегии нет. Стратегия - это линия
поведения. Это плановая линия поведения.
Я буду делать это, а это делать не буду.
Я буду двигаться в эту сторону, а вот в
эту сторону двигаться не буду. Поэтому
вот, чтобы вы понимали различия между
стратегией и планами и стратегией и
тактикой. А в целом обычно принято
принимать за стратегию то, что там
планы, условно говоря, на 3, 5, 10 и
далее лет в зависимости от горизонта
планирования человека. Но обычно годовые
планы никто не называет стратегией. Но
мы, идя на поводу у маркетинга, чтобы
привлечь ваше внимание, назвали
стратегией а на поведение на на двадцать
третий год. И хотелось бы послушать, как
наши участники нашей программы сегодня
планируют свой год, э в каком
направлении планируют двигаться и вообще
есть ли планы, потому что аэ некоторые
[откашливается] творческие люди говорят:
"Я вообще почине плыву". И это их вполне
их устраивает. И это тоже норм. Это тоже
норм. Поэтому,
Арман, как ты, да,
как ты выстраиваешь? Ну, ты как раз по
алфавиту. А, Арман,
как по алфавиту, кстати, Д точно, они
они правильно. А, Амирхан здесь тоже на
А
как вообще ты видишь линию свою плановую
линию ээ поведения на двадцать третий
год? Какие наметил цели? И какие
лайфхаки мог бы посоветовать нашим
зрителям, как планировать?
Ну, лайфхак, наверное, не планирую идти
ничего на январь.
Так, ну почему? Потому что начало года,
последние, наверное, 3-4 года, вот шутка
была про трёх всадников Апокалипсиса,
когда сварщик был, который взорвал там
порт, да, целый, а потом был убийство
там иранского э полковника и так далее,
и так далее. Да. Вот последние 3-4 года
потрясения большие приходятся на январь
месяц.
затрагиваю события, они имеют особое
место в истории Казахстана, а имею в
виду предыдущие годы. И как минимум
лайфхак - это пусть январь начнётся и
там уже будет видно. Как минимум на
начало года я больше таких каких-то
грандиозных для себя планов не оставлю.
Угу.
А что касаемо такой стратегической
линии, я для себя определил классную
статью прочитал, называется Роль
корпоративного центра. Это Гарвард
бизнесрев, о котором говорится о четырёх
видов вообще уровня бизнеса. Самый
нижний - это оператор, потом контролёр,
архитектор и инвестор.
Угу.
И понял то, что всю свою жизнь я
занимался тем, что был операционистом,
который строит бизнесы очень много и при
этом сам ручками это всё делает. И вот
это как раз укладывается в ту концепцию,
которую вы нас всегда обучаете, о том,
что меньше работать и больше
зарабатывать, больше свободного времени
на себя, на семью. И хочу расти по этому
уровню вверх, дойти до инвестора. И план
на двадцать третий год мой - это в
первой половине выйти полностью
операционно, к концу года пересесть на
кресло инвестора, а направить свой взор
на более, скажем так, активные рынки
мировые
и начать плавать как рыба там. Вот
двадцать четвёртый год у меня на
двадцать четвёртый год грандиозные
планы. И Аллажаса, если всё в двадцать
третьем году всё получится. На двадцать
четвёртый год я хотел бы а уже быть на
тех рынках, активных рынках, это
западные, это Персидского залива, а и
заниматься, скажем так, активным
инвестированием в такие гигиче.
То есть двадцать третий год ты будешь
строить фундамент для прыжка в двадцать
четвёртый год.
Двадцат четыртый год, да. Такая
стратегия.
Понятно, Дина.
Я в стратегии
больше поисков себя, потому что учитывая
то, что двадцать второй год и очень
много трат было, а были кое-какие
упещения, то, что я ещё тестировала,
находилась много времени в Казахстане и
хотела посмотреть, а как вообще без то
есть дистанционное управление.
Угу.
То есть к чему это привело. Не было
роста, но тем не менее оно как бы
двигалось. Вот.
Мы не упали и не выросли. Вот. Тем не
менее хочу больше внимания в этом году
сделать так, чтобы был рост. Угу.
А, несмотря на то, что в какой Да,
дистанционное управление, несмотря на
то, что где я нахожусь, потому что
а девушка, когда делает бизнес, а у
многих страдает семейная часть. Это, ну,
большинство так в моей жизни это,
наверное, тоже. И как бы вторая - это
больше, наверное, стать той девушкой
слабой, научиться действительно вот, э,
принимать, я не знаю, найти, наверное,
такой уронманкой в женственность,
да, [смех] можно так сказать,
вот больше, наверное, да, потому что
бизнес с бизнесом, но семья тоже надо.
Угу. Вот поэтому и в плане, если
бизнеса, это вот мы сейчас получается
вот развитие своего личного бренда, а
правильно выйти на зарубежные, это вот
на маркетплейсах. И третье направление -
это именно в Казахстане хочу грамотно
развить оптовые продажи.
То есть мы с 2022 года счёт этого вот
работаем упорно. Не знаю, куда это
приведёт.
Угу.
Тем не менее планы пока такие. Угу. Так,
рад. А так планы [откашливается] на
двадцать третий год. А, ну,
ну, стратегия или линия поведения, ска.
Линия поведения. Ну, а у меня большие
ожидания. Я снял фильм и буду доснимать
его, и, скорее всего, я выйду в прокат с
документальным фильмом. И я думаю, что
да, это вот мой план следующего года. А
фильм будет называться Карапереште,
чёрный ангел. Это фильм про семью. Ну и
в целом в этом фильме, то есть это очень
много там аспектов своих. Это вот
проект, которым я как бы сейчас, ну, не
то чтобы живу, но он мне очень меня
возвращает меня именно вот к творчеству
истинным. Также я планирую заниматься
Ютубом, планирую заниматься
продюсированием, хочу запуститься,
запустить несколько программ на Ютубе.
также буду развиваться. Ну и в целом я
бы очень бы такой больше, наверное, хочу
посвятить время своей семье, воспитывать
сына, проводить больше времени в
путешествиях с семьёй.
А да, наверное, двадцать третий год. У
меня нет никаких, да, ожиданий. Я вот
тот, наверное, самый творческий человек,
который течёт по течению. Но
Но всё равно есть определённые,
э, направления, назовём это так,
направление на публично. должен быть
лучше двадцать второго года.
Ну, в целом у тебя направление на
публичность,
на на влияние на публичность,
да, на публичность. Второе, на семью.
И хочу, э, выступить в нескольких там
спортивных соревнований по боксу. Я
занимаюсь боксом как 2 года.
Угу.
И в принципе неплохо получается. В
двадцать втором году я выступил разок. И
в двадцать третьем я бы хотел бы ещё
несколько раз выступить там, ну, в
любительском,
подтянуть свою спортивную часть.
Ну да, да.
Угу. То есть спорт,
спорт, бизнес, менталь. Ну это всё
такое, это же всё связано.
Угу.
Так, Амерхан.
А, да, у меня тоже, наверное, два самых
момента. Первое - это то, что всё-таки
мне остаётся там быть одним из лидеров
американского рынка по автоматизации
парковок. И поэтому я на этапе сейчас
получения инвесторской визы. И д третий
год я преимущественного штатах проведу.
Аа вот желание, чтобы американский рынок
стал основным, желание, чтобы там, а, на
зарубежных рынках зарабатывать 99%
доходов, чтобы не зависит от
макроэкономической прочее ситуации в
Казахстане. Это основный момент, как бы,
над чем мы сильно работаем. А второй
момент, который я заметил, э, э, то есть
когда нужно много летать, когда нужно
там условно ночью просыпаться, проводить
зумколы с Америкой или, наоборот, в
Америке ночью просыпаться и проводить
зумколы с Казахстаном и так далее. В
этом году как бы, наверное, половину
года я провёл тем, что болел, разные
болезни, там недосып давления, там
нехватка витаминов и так далее, и так
далее. В этом плане, а понял, что
здоровье прямо суперважно для
эффективного бизнеса. А вы тоже говорили
это в своих многих подкастах бизнес, да,
в этом плане охота быть в состоянии
работать 12-15 часов сутки. Я думаю, это
суперважно ближайшие, по крайней мере,
несколько лет, потому что основной фокус
- это бизнес, и нужно как бы иногда
замечаю прямую корреляцию, насколько
эффективен я, насколько эффективен и
бизнес, как бы в этом плане. Вот два.
Основное - это там в Америке
закрепиться, а второй - это быть в
состоянии работать 12-15 часов в сутки,
в ближайшие 3 года.
Классно. Классно.
Можно сюда добавить?
Для меня в этом году тоже открытие было.
Поговорив с Алексеем Васильевичем. У
меня, кстати, новый наставник Алексеем
Васильевич, и он мне говорит: "Поставь
себе трёхлетнюю спортивную цель".
Я го Я не понимал, ну зачем? Может, это
дисциплинировать в бизнесе, ещё что-то.
А потом, разговаривая, он говорит: "80%
всего, что там мы там, не знаю, кушаем и
так далее, всю энергию сосёт наш мозг".
И вот если у тебя тело начинает сбоить,
то у тебя там память хуже становится,
там мыслительные процессы плохо идут. Я
так понял, то, что спорт - это
поддержание очень хорошо своего тела.
Соответственно, это забота о своём мозге
на перспективу. И он говорит: "Вот тебе
сейчас 31 год. Ты сейчас высасываешь
всё, что тебе природы дано, у тебя там
классный метаболизм, хорошо раз, а вот
что будет с тобой через 10 лет? Ты
будешь тем же самым Арманом красавчиком,
который быстро думает там, я не знаю,
насчёт красавчика, [смех]
но он но он так ответил. А он так
ответил. [смех]
Это цитата.
После этого он стал наставником.
Я заплатил 15 млн тенге. Да.
[смех]
И я поставил себе такую цель. Я очень
боюсь воды, не плаваю вообще. И в этом
году моя цель Ocean Man покорить 15 км.
На второй год - это 5 км и на третий год
10 км. Вот такую себе такую спортивную
цель поставил, потому что я заметил, что
если просто ходить там на тренировки, то
это как делать бизнес просто ради
бизнеса. А когда есть вот конкретная
цель, как и в бизнесе, да, там чётко, а
в спорте тоже ты не можешь себе уже
позволить не ходить или там в отпуск
уехал, не тренироваться. У меня осталось
всего полгода, и мне нужно вот Копчагай
проплыть полтора. [смех]
Классно. Я в целом хотел бы зрителям
ввести в курс. Я просто
думаю, что многие зрители ещё не пришли
к тому, чтобы выстраивать стратегию в
отношении года планирования и так далее.
естественно, ждут каких-то лайфхаков от
меня, от гостей и так далее. Я поэтому
хотел бы м показать, насколько это
важно, ээ иметь определённую стратегию
на год, потому что, смотрите,
есть два типа жизни. Один тип жизни,
когда случается событие,
а потом ты думаешь, как на это событие
реагировать, и после этого ты
выстраиваешь свою линию поведения под
событие. То есть, смотрите, сначала
событие случаются, потом вы производите
оценку этого события, подгоняете своё
мировоззрение под текущую ситуацию,
которая сложилась, и потом выстраиваете
себе такой определённый план выживания
или адаптации к этому событию. А, и
большинство людей это делают на
автопилоте. Вы даже это не осознаёте, но
без плана не двигается никто. Вы
думаете, что у вас нету планов. На самом
деле у вас планы есть. Просто другой
вопрос, что они у вас в голове эти
планы. Так вот, а есть другой тип
поведения, когда вы не смотрите на то
событие, которое случилось, вы
выстраиваете то событие или ту картинку
мира, ту реальность, в которой вы хотели
бы жить,
и от неё уже назад планируете, какие
действия нужно сделать, чтобы оказаться
в том мире, в котором вы хотите.
Поэтому, когда мы говорим про
стратегическую линию поведения, мы
подразумеваем вот этот второй тип. То
есть не приспосабливаться и
адаптироваться к тем событиям, которые
случились уже, а
подстраивать тот мир, ту реальность под
ту, которую вы хотите, в которой вы
хотите оказаться, в которой вы хотите
жить. Поэтому планирование - это очень
важный инструмент выстраивания вашей
будущей реальности, которая отвечает
вашим целям и которая вам нужна. Теперь,
а, с точки зрения детализации
планирования, аа, ну, в целом, если вам
интересна система планирования,
управление жизненной энергией и так
далее, вашим вниманием и так далее, то у
меня есть курс для этого специальный,
называется кайзин планирование. Там уже
больше 4,5 млн просмотров. Можете
посмотреть это в бесплатном доступе. А,
ну или курс там у меня на платформе
образовательной. Так вот, смотрите, что
такое стратегическая стратегия вообще на
год.
Есть люди, которые боятся вот этих
подробных
планов. Вот это, вот это. И многие люди
говорят, некоторые не
дисциплинированные, а некоторые
творческие люди. То есть есть люди,
которые называют себя творческими
людьми. [смех]
Это я шучу специальный камень в сторону
творческих людей. Но на самом деле,
смотрите, если вы не хотите заниматься
вот этой рутиной планирования, то вы
можете выстроить стратегическую, э
взгляд, стратегическую линию. То есть
берёте год и говорите, что в этом году я
основное внимание буду уделять спорту и
либо вот, как ребята говорят, экспансию
на внешние рынки. Этот год посвящаем
внешнему рынку. Э либо, как она говорит,
этот год я посвящаю там семье э
какой-то. Это поставьте себе просто, я
ещё называю облако интересов.
Облако интересов - это слова, которые на
которые которые вы всё время будете
держать в голове на протяжении всего
года. Вы говорите: "Так, в этом году мои
приоритеты потянуть здоровье. Так, в
этом году мои приоритеты больше уделять
внимание семье". Так, третье. В этом
году мои приоритеты отойти от
операционки в бизнесе. Всё. Три. Три
этих слова вы будете весь год держать в
голове. И, соответственно, все ваши
действия, все ваши планы, все ваши мысли
будут автоматически подгоняться под эти
три, а, приоритета. Попробуйте, это
очень просто. Это не совсем не сложно.
Для этого не надо заполнять какие-то
подробные планы и так далее. Но в то же
время это гораздо сильнее, чем просто
там, знаете, облако желаний или лист
желаний, когда ты написал свои желания,
сжёг, бросил шампанское и выпил. Ну это
полная чушь собак, сейчас сразу вам
скажу. А здесь это более конкретный
инструмент. Поэтому, когда мы говорим
про стратегию на двадцать третий год, мы
подразумеваем ту линию поведения,
планируемую линию поведения, которая
будет выстраивать весь весь ваш год. Это
лайфхак специально не для тех, кто умеет
планировать, а больше для тех, кто не
хочет планировать, не умеет, не
дисциплинировать. У меня просьба,
попробуйте э с стратегической линией
поведения и увидите, гораздо легче вам
будет принимать решение в течение года.
Итак, так как у нас это предновогодний
выпуск, я хотел бы,
подводя к завершению, чтобы вы сказали
своё пожелание, наверное, зрителям в
целом ваше отношение к планированию, ещё
какие-то, если есть лайфхаки, может
какие-то фишки вставите и пожелания на
двадцать третий год. Э и на этом будем
потихоньку их завершать.
По традиции, да, по традиции мы начинаем
с буквы А.
Такой лайфхак, наверное, который я
получил также от Марланч- это всегда
цель держать перед глазами. Вот неважно,
вы напишите это на бумажке или же там
стратегическую линию свою выстроите, но
главное во время вот этой суеты, когда
год будет идти то одно, то другое, то
второе, то третье, всё время напоминать
себе, а какую же цель я всё-таки себе на
этот год ставил. А я лично это делаю
через то, что пишу, а там большими
буквами. Это висит у меня в комнате или
в офисе. Я всё время себе напоминаю:
"Тактактак, что-то ты засуетился, что-то
ты вот не туда идёшь". Вот она цель,
куда мы идём. И вот такой вот лайфхак я
использую в своей жизни. Он мне достался
от моего наставника. А желаю вам на этот
следующий год самое главное - это
здоровье. Берите эти свои семьи. Мы
видим то, что время оно неспокойно, и
самое главное - это наши родные,
близкие.
А давайте беречь наш язык, развивать
его. И вот всего наилучшего на двадцать
третий год желаю.
Я, наверное, не знаю, лайфхаков очень
много,
очень много рассказывает, но, наверное,
самые первые оставаться всегда самим
собой, быть тем, кем ты являешься, и не
стараться казаться ни на какие влияния,
да, и [фыркает] всегда действительно
идти к тому, что ты в душе сильно
хочешь. То есть постоянно идти к своей
цели, чтобы не произошло, какие
ситуации. То есть всегда нужно дойти. И
так как я очень люблю путешествовать,
вот благодаря бакетлисту
планировал, кстати, забыла сказать,
звучит какой-то баке какой-то благодаря
Бакему.
Вот Эст и Berн и очень впечатление.
Поэтому желаю всем, наверное, а, крутых
эмоций, потому что действительно, а
эмоции это влияет на нашу жизнь, так как
на стратегию, как мы настроены, да,
энергии побольше и добивайтесь своих
целей.
Угу.
А нам захоть придётся. [смех]
Кто-то кайфует, отдыхает там.
На самом деле Дина очень важную вещь
затронула. Дело в том, что если бы в
нашей жизни не было бы эмоций, то это
был бы карандашный набросок,
чёрно-белый карандашный набросток.
Согласен.
Всё, что красит нашу жизнь - это только
наши эмоции. Поэтому в жизни
коллекционируйте эмоции. Вот в этом
плане творческие люди, они более яркие,
богатые люди, потому что у них развито
воображение, и они эмоционально
реагируют на многие события.
Эмоциональная реакция на многие события
очень плохо влияет на принятие здравых
разумных решений, но с другой стороны
она окрашивает нашу жизнь. Поэтому не
увлекайтесь слишком тем, что там быть
совсем здравым, умным,
плановым и так далее. Не забывайте в это
время проживать жизнь. Не забывайте в
конечном итоге мы всё время, что мы чем
мы занимаемся в течение всей жизни, мы
коллекционируем библиотеку наших эмоций.
Да. Поэтому
спасибович действительно, да, программа
очень классная. Это не реклама, это
просто я люблю путешествовать,
а поэтому одному неинтересно. И
действительно, когда группа интересных
людей собираются, а, учитывая опыт Баги,
Японии, да, вот очень классно. Поэтому
благодарна действительно то, что так
получилось и на этот год вот
запланирован.
Твои пожелания? Пожелание
действительно, как Арман сказал, самое
главное здоровье посалат. Вот и
достижение своих целей. А пусть будет
мир и добра, учитывая то, что мы
проживаем сейчас. Вот. Всем хорошего
достижения, наверное, результатов, а
целей, планы.
Всего хорошего,
канат.
Ой, ну вашим зрителям я только пожелаю,
э не буду многословно, пожелаю любви. Э
пусть любви будет в следующем году
больше.
А, да, любовь победит зло. [смех]
Угу.
А желаю быть всем в тонусе. А вот тоже
если взять последние 3 года или в целом
последние там последние годы, а, и опять
же, когда мы читаем книжки того же Насим
Талеба, да, там, то есть в целом как бы
консенсус такой, что мир всё дальше,
дальше будет непредсказуемым, уровень
непредсказуемости и контроля над жизнью,
над событием, оно будет дальше расти. А
вот на примере той же Америки, допустим,
за последний год взять там сотни тысяч
людей остались без работы в сфере IT,
где там вроде все растут, а сотни тысяч
стартапов умерли, начиная там банально
криптобирж, заканчивая там сервисами
доставки еды, а рынок там динамичный,
поэтому там это, наверное, остре острее
ээ чувствуется. В этом плане, как бы, а
не надо ожидать, э, какую-то как бы
спокойности, то, что всё вернётся в
круги своя, что потом жизнь станет тише,
там, не знаю, там политическая
обстановка станет лучше, да? То есть на
фоне на фоне того, что у нас там
конфликт Китай, Америка или Украина
Россия, мы забыли, что там через границу
у нас тамбан находится, да, как бы в
этом плане уровень непредсказуемости он
будет дальше расти. В этом плане как бы
единственная стратегия, наверное, это
всегда нужно быть в тонусе, быть живым.
А ментально и физически в хорошем
состоянии, чтобы неважно там в каком
состоянии бизнес, неважно в каком
состоянии ситуация, обстоятельства
вокруг, если ты живой и если у тебя там
трезвый хороший рассудок, там как бы всё
можно решить.
Пожелания нашим
пожелания. Вот всем хорошего тонуса,
спорта. Да, спасибо. Но я, подытоживая
наш Гем подкаст, тоже хотел бы высказать
своё м не то что мнение, а свой
небольшой лайфхак. Сегодня буквально
прочитал в Telegram-канале аа
такое хорошее высказывание. Говорит:
"Пока ожидаемое стучится в дверь,
непредсказуемое уже сидит за столом и
пьёт кофе".
Так вот, смотрите, я исправил, вернее,
дополнил это высказывание. Оно очень
красивое, хорошее высказывание,
образное. Я дополнил его таким образом.
Пока ожидаемое стучится в дверь, вы
должны сделать так, чтобы ваше
запланированное заняло всё места и не
оставалось место для непредсказуемых
гостей.
Классно.
Поэтому планируйте
двадцать третий год. Невзираемо,
невзирая на те, э события, которые
произойдут, всегда следуйте своим
курсом. Потому что когда корабль
движется к своей цели, происходят и
штормы, происходят и штиль. Но это не
значит, что корабль должен перестать
двигаться к своей цели.
Поддерживая точку зрения Амирхана,
события с каждым днём только ускоряются.
Мир в целом ускоряется. Если вы
посмотрите, какой информационный бал
валится на всех нас, то это
информационное цунами поглощает всех нас
и уменьшает нашу эффективность. А есть
ещё такой закон: чем выше скорость, тем
больше рисков.
В целом общество, человечество
сталкивается с с информационным балом. И
сейчас все процессы двигаются очень
быстро. То, что мы раньше месяцами
согласовывали поставки там чего-то, одну
встречу по телефону, 2 дня
согласовывали, сейчас по Ватсаппу мы с
любой точки мира или по телеграмму
решаем всё. Вот я до этого до этого гемб
подкаста 4 часа провёл в зумах, а зумы с
различными людьми, партнёрами с других
стран и так далее. Всё движется очень
быстро. А когда всё движется очень
быстро, то риски нарастают. раз
нарастают риски, значит, будет всё
больше, больше непредсказуемых событий.
А от того, что их становится больше, это
не значит, что мы должны прекратить и
перестать жить и перестать бороться. Я
считаю, что мы должны научиться
справляться с этим, а для этого мы
должны работать над своей
подготовленностью. Мы должны выстраивать
свою линию поведения, свою линию
поведения. Как китайцы говорят, у
корабля, у которого нету цели, никогда
не бывает попутного ветра. Так вот, для
того, чтобы у вас был попутный ветер,
всегда выстраивайте свои цели,
выстраивайте линию поведения, не
поддавайтесь ни на какие изменения и
непредсказуемости, которые случаются в
вашей жизни. Быдьте, Будьте неуклонны,
стремитесь к счастью, не забывайте
проживать эту жизнь и проживать эти
эмоции. В конечном итоге наибольшую
ценность имеет наша жизнь и то, как мы
проживаем. На этом мы прощаемся. Спасибо
всем нашим гостям. Спасибо всем
организаторам, операторам и до новых
встреч. Желаю вам удачи и успехов в
двадцать третьем году.
Дорогие друзья, пользуясь случаем,
позвольте мне вручить вам новогодние
подарки от компании Marн Healthс. Это
то, что мы говорим сегодня много о
здоровье. И вот как раз в наших наборах
есть частичка японского здоровья,
долголетия. Хотел бы вручить вам. И это
тот случай, когда вопрос не касается
лечения болезней, а больше профилактики
здоровья, что гораздо важнее.
Да. Вот такие вот у меня подарочки.
Спасибо. Спасибо большое.
Так нет, девушкам подарок не отдишь.
Морлачи мы каждый разчаем [смех]
кожи.
Спасибо большое. Супер.
Спасибо огромное.
Здесь такой набор, да, пакет.
Очень красиво. Очень крутой блокнот
компании Mars.
Это наш такой бестселлер продукт Ашикаба
из Японии.
Здесь есть и который как раз-таки
помогает справляться со всеми
неблагоприятными
ситуациями.
Да. Вот такой вот набор от нашей
компании. Спасибо.
Спасибо большое.